now if there's any doubt clearly
russia's invasion is about to get way
way worse than even many anticipated
with more indiscriminate bombing raids
against innocent civilians and today fox
news learned that russia has drafted
plans to conduct public executions in
ukrainian cities once they've been
captured now russia's murdering thug
vladimir putin he's got to be stopped by
somebody and i've said repeatedly no not
one american boot on the ground i've
called for both america and europe if
you want sanctions that will work the
first sanction the top sanction the most
immediate damage you can do to putin's
economy is to stop importing energy from
russia and for america to immediately
return to energy independence as soon as
possible like we achieved under
president trump now i support america
supplying ukraine with the javelin
missiles like president trump did i had
my doubts at the time and america's
supplying stinger missiles to ukraine
like president reagan provided the
mujahideen in afghanistan in the 80s i
also add that anyone that invades a
sovereign country even one with a
history of corruption like ukraine we've
been very outspoken about it quid pro
quo joe and if they kill innocent men
women and children like vladimir putin
has here they forfeit their right to
lead a country they deserve to be taken
out by any means necessary and our hope
is maybe someone in vladimir putin's
inner circle has a conscience and a soul
and would be able to
refuse to be a part of a regime that is
guilty of murdering women and children
now meanwhile every dollar that we spend
on russian oil is a dollar that goes
right into vladimir putin's fund for his
war crimes in ukraine and right now
we're spending billions of dollars
buying over 600 000 barrels of oil from
russia every single day and as democrat
joe manchin said we either expand our
fossil fuel industry here or we end up
compromised just like countries like
germany take a listen
we have to have energy independent you
cannot be the superpower of the world if
you have to depend on other nations to
produce your energy and that i'm just in
a different place than than my caucus or
the colleagues or the president and they
have a hard time coming to grips that
you've got to use everything you've got
you've got to use your gas you've got to
use your coal you've got to use your oil
and you have to develop wind and solar
and hydro and geothermal and hydrogen
all these things i'm for
but i'm not going to leave us in a void
larry i'm just not going to basically go
down that path and end up like germany
did
joe manchin is 100 right we have enough
oil we have enough gas we have enough
natural resources right here in america
to supply our own energy needs and the
needs of our allies for 100 years plus
in fact the european union also has
tremendous tremendous amounts of natural
energy they're not using it take a look
at your screen europe's dependence on
russian gas is not out of necessity it's
the choice they've made
as a matter of fact in a fake political
effort to go green european government
literally stopped
tapping their own supply of natural gas
and then imported it from russia as a
matter of fact europe gets 40 percent of
the natural gas from russia now putin by
the way has them literally no pun
intended over a barrel now the
dependence on oil and gas has got to end
in fact today even nancy pelosi came out
in support of banning all russian oil
imports into the u.s
likely an election year conversion
but she still has yet to speak out about
america once again reclaiming energy
independence now of course joe biden he
just isn't willing to make that
commitment take a look
mr mr president mr president speaker
mr president speaker pelosi said
speaker pelosi says russian oil should
be banned why not do it now thank you
let's go out the door come on turn
around will sanctions be on thank you
guys out the door let's go thank you
will you ban russians
remember joe needs to get permission to
answer any questions it's pathetic then
later in the afternoon jan saki circled
back to those questions and said there's
absolutely nothing the big
administration can do to curb our
dependence on foreign oil
all of the restrictions that they have
placed
on energy
exploration and production
is something they can stop and lift
immediately and to blame the oil
companies is laughable take a look
on gas you just said that you know less
supply raises prices it's not in our
strategic interest to reduce the supply
we also know you know the president as
recently is yesterday talked about
increasing domestic manufacturing to
bring down prices on inflated items like
goods
so why not apply the same logic to
energy and increase domestic production
here
well there are 9 000 approved oil leases
that the oil companies are not tapping
into currently so i would ask them that
question you think that opening the
keystone pipeline and having more energy
friendly policies might do that the
keystone pipeline has never been
operational it would take years for that
to have any impact
they shut down auctions they shut down
exploration they shut down alaska they
shut down anwar they shut down the
keystone xl pipeline and jinsaki is
basically just lying under the last
administration the u.s was a net
exporter of energy joe biden gave that
up because he caved to the radical new
green deal socialists that run his party
now that was before biden blocked expo
exploration on lands blocked new
drilling efforts in alaska killed the
keystone xl pipeline enacted a variety
of regulations on the oil and gas
industry and he needs to lift them all
now joe biden is not willing of course
to reverse course on any of these
restrictions no matter how high the
price of a gallon of gasoline goes
doesn't matter how much you pay for
groceries and every store and every
product that you buy in any store you
the american people will pay the price
that's one of the big reasons we have a
40-year high with inflation joe biden is
too cowardly too gutless to stand up to
the radical climate alarmist cult that
is the democratic party base he'd rather
just import the oil from putin last year
232 million barrels of oil from putin
600 millions barrels of oil from opec a
million from iran we haven't done that
since 1991. putin by the way
we're still importing oil as he is
waging an assault on humanity in ukraine
that's right he's killing even women and
children but according to biden well
putin's bloody invasion of ukraine has
nothing to do with joe's weakness on the
world stage or the humiliating
withdrawal from afghanistan and by the
way it's day 201 since he abandoned our
fellow americans that are trapped behind
enemy lines in afghanistan instead
according to joe putin invaded ukraine
because of january 6.
wrong joe take a look
vladimir putin
was counting on being able to split up
the united states
look
how would you feel
if you saw
crowds
storm and break down the doors of the
british parliament i think you'd wonder
well that's what the rest of the world
saw
it's not who we are
well maybe with the speaker of the house
and the mayor of d.c
had taken donald trump as required by
law he signed off on as many as 20 000
national guard troops on that day did it
two days earlier and maybe if they
listen to the capitol police chief maybe
if nancy pelosi did her job and bowser
did her job hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else